heights funeral home in henderson will
be closing its doors at midnight the
state suspended the mortuary from
operating for six months after several
violations were discovered joe mohler is
live at boulder highway and sunset with
what the funeral director says about the
shutdown joe
denise the funeral director says that
the remaining bodies had been removed
from the heights funeral home here in
henderson she says the suspension should
send a message when it comes to the
treatment of the deceased
once they got our money it was like
almost nearly impossible to get a hold
of anyone ashley brazil's father was
recently cremated at heights when i
received him i expected to like have
this like sense of peace and i
didn't you know it was just like
is it even him she says this suspension
does not come as a surprise there won't
be any decedents at the location they're
certainly not selling any more services
jennifer kant is the state funeral board
director she flew in from reno to
oversee this process in august the board
suspended the company's license after a
list of alleged violations were reported
and pictured including stacking of
bodies something that is against the law
she says bunker's mortuary in las vegas
stepped up to take the remaining roughly
40 bodies and that's a big deal because
these are cases that other funeral homes
don't necessarily want to take you know
they've been around a while most of them
are social service cases kant hopes this
suspension sends a message about the
treatment of those who have passed it is
very important to the families
and so i hope that they do get that
message that it matters brazil hopes the
state keeps an eye on heights they were
able to be monitored monitored more
closely i think that that would be very
very important
a representative from bunker's mortuary
told me they believe it is their moral
and ethical responsibility to assist
the families who are still grieving
reporting live in henderson joe mohler
live local now